Yeah,
I've really been trying to understand
the underlying psychology of
postmodernism and its relationship with
neo Marxism and then the spread of that
into the universities and the effect on
the culture and what I would like to
start with is a description of your
understanding of that because our,
like I've presented to the people who
are listening to me,
my understanding of it.
I interviewed Steven Hicks recently and
he wrote an interesting book called
explaining postmodernism,
which I liked quite a bit.
It's been criticized for being too right
wing,
although I don't think he's right wing
at all.
I think maybe you could characterize
them as middle of the road conservative,
but I would say he's more like a classic
liberal,
but I'm really curious about your views
about what,
what,
what postmodernism is.
First of all,
I know you've,
you've identified it with the,
with the general tricksters,
Duroda and Latina and Sukkot and
football in particular you've talked
about,
but I'd like to know what you think
about postmodernism and also why you
think it's been so attractive to people.
Well,
my explanation is that there is no
authentic 19 sixties point of view in
any of the elite universities.
Okay.
But rather,
the most liberated minds of my
generation were 1960.
It did not go onto graduate school.
I witnessed with my own eyes.
I saw genuine marxists.
Okay.
At my college,
which was the State University of New
York at Binghamton,
upstate New York,
a Harper College,
which had a huge cohort of very radical
downstate New York Jews.
Okay.
Who,
in fact,
the Harper,
what we used to be called Berkeley East.
So I saw genuine,
passionate marxists with my own eyes.
They were not word choppers at.
They were not snide postmodernists,
right?
They weren't in your face aggressive.
They use the language of the people.
They had a populist energy.
Hey,
they dressed working class.
There were non materialistic.
Hey,
these are people who lived by their own
convictions.
They were against the graduate school.
So when I,
when I,
uh,
went onto graduate school and it became
known that I was going to go to Yale,
I was confronted by a leader of the
radicals on campus or in broad daylight
in front of everyone who denounced me
for Grad school is not where it's
happening.
You don't,
you don't do that.
If you have to go to graduate school,
you should go to buffalo now.
And I had applied to these students to
suny buffalo because the great leftist
critic,
Leslie fiedler was there.
What a huge impact on me.
He's right.
He created,
created identity politics,
but without its present distortions,
uh,
and Norman Holland,
the second one,
little critic was there.
I will be very happy to have gone onto
buffalo,
but I needed the library again.
So I continued on to.
Yeah,
the word no in the,
in the graduate schools from 1968 to 72
when I was there were only one radical
todd Gitlin.
Okay.
Went on to have a career success.
The actual radicals of the 19 sixties,
right.
Either when off dropped out of college
and went off to create commune.
So I or they were taking acid and
destroyed their brains.
Now I have also written about that,
the destruction of the of the minds.
Okay.
I'll for the most talented members of my
generation through Lsd,
it was going on all around me towards
what's happened is the actual legacy of
the sixties got truncated.
The idea that these poststructuralist
and postmodernist are heirs of the 1960
[inaudible] revolution is an absolute
crock.
Okay.
What they represent as Fuko shows,
shows Fuko said,
okay,
the biggest influence on on his thinking
was Samuel Beckett's waiting for Godot.
Okay.
Which was a post World War Two play
written in Paris.
That was about the disillusionment and
nihilism experienced after Hitler went
through occupied France and all of
Europe was in ruins and had nothing to
do.
Waiting for Godot has nothing to do with
the authentic legacy of the 19 sixties,
which was about genuine
multiculturalism,
a movement toward India.
Hinduism.
I a transformation of consciousness
through psychedelics,
which I take but which identify with
totally through the music,
etc.
Right?
It was a turn toward the body.
It was a tuRn towards sensory
experience.
Okay.
I'm not this,
this word shopping thing and this
cynical removal from an actual
experience that french import.
Okay.
Came in.
To the graduate school,
it did not affect any genuine 19 sixties
person.
The real 19 sixties revolution was about
young.
It was about a way of seeing the cosmos
in mythological terms and the union
contribution went on into the new age
movement of the 19 seventies.
Aside from the universities.
So who took over the universities were
these careerists hey,
I saw them with my own eyes.
I saw what happened.
I thought I was at yale when derrida was
being shipped over to,
to address the,
uh,
you know,
the,
the student is around students and the
faculty.
And I said to a fellow student after
hearing one of these guys speak.
It wasn't dairy die.
It was,
it wasn't another one of the theorists.
I said,
they are like high priests murmuring to
each other.
This,
this was an elitist form from the start.
Okay.
It was not progressive.
It was not revolutionary.
It was reactionary.
It was a desperate attempt to hold on to
what had happened before.
The 19 sixties sensory revolution was
this postmodernist thing.
Okay.
This trashing.
Of of the text.
This is this,
this encouragement.
Okay.
Have a superior and destructive attitude
toward the work of art that we're going
through.
It's okay.
Primly with red pen in hand.
Finding all the evidence of sexism.
Check racism,
check homophobia.
Check.
That is not the empathic emotional.
Okay.
Sensory based.
A revolution of the 19 sixties I,
I am sick and tired of these people
claiming any kind of mental from the 19
sixties.
They're frauds.
These people are.
What happened in the 19 seventies was a
collapse of the job market in academia.
All of a sudden those jobs were scarce
and this thing was there.
The new and improved and shiny thing to
be a fearless.
People seized on it.
It was institutionalized and it's an
enormous betrayal of the 1960
[inaudible].
Can you.
You touched on this idea of the
destruction of the work of art.
You know,
and one of the things I really liked
about reading nature was his discussion
of resolved them all right,
of resentment and,
and it seems to me that a tremendous
amount of the motive power that drives
the postmodernist,
let's call it,
it's not a revolution.
Um,
transformation seems to me to be driven
by resentment about virtually anything
that has any.
Well,
what would you say?
Any merIt of competence or aesthetic
quality.
And I don't know if that's,
it seems to me that that's partly rooted
in the academics.
Disdain for the business world,
which I think is driven by their
relative economic inequality because
most people who are as intelligent as
academics are from a pure iq point of
view make more money in the private
sphere.
And so I think that drives some of it.
but there also seems to be this.
There's a destruction on aim for
destruction of the,
of the aesthetic quality of the,
of the literary or artistic work.
It's reduction to nothing but some kind
of power game.
And then surrounding that,
the reduction of everything to something
that approximates a power gate,
which,
which I can't help but identifying with
jealousy and resentment as a,
as a fundamental motivator.
Does that seem reasonable to you?
Professors?
Okay.
Who allege at art is nothing but an
ideological movement by one elite,
a against the against another group,
right?
These people are philistines the
philistines.
They're middlebrow,
hopelessly middlebrow,
or they.
They have no sense of beauty.
They have no sense of the aesthetic.
Now,
marxism doesn't need a search.
This moccasin tries to reconfigure the
universe in terms of materialism.
It says it does not recognize any kind
of spiritual dimension.
Now I'm an atheist,
but I see the great world religions as
enormous works of art as the,
as the,
as the best way to understand the
universe and man's place in it.
I find them enOrmously moving that
they're there.
They're like enormous pole,
and I and I would,
I have called for the true revolution.
Okay.
Would have been okay to make the core
currIculum of world education the world.
Okay.
The great religions of the world feel
that is the only way to achieve an
understanding and it's also a way to,
to,
to present the aesthetic.
Okay.
Because I feel that,
that the,
that the real sixties' vision was about
xcel,
taishan,
elevation,
cosmic consciousness.
So I,
all of these things were rejected.
Okay.
By these,
by these midgets.
Okay.
Intellectual midgets who seized onto
lecan,
derrida and fuko.
Right.
It's an and my career has been in the
art school.
So I made my entire career beginning of
anything college.
Uh,
so I,
I represent a challenge to this from the
perspective of art.
It is an absolute nonsense.
Okay.
As post structuralism maintains that
reality is mediated by language,
by words.
Everything that we can know,
including gender is absolutely madness
because I'm,
I'm teaching students whose majors are
ceramics.
Okay.
Our dance.
Who are jazz musicians who understand
reality in terms of the body.
It's sensory activation.
So now what?
See,
what happened was something was going on
in the art world as well.
I identify with andy warhol and pop art.
Okay.
That was what was going on during my
years in college.
Everything about andy warhol was like,
wow,
admiration.
Wow.
What happened immediately after that in
the arts?
Nineteen seventies.
okay.
Was this collapse into a snide sort of
postmodernism?
also?
This happened in the art world and it
was an utter misunderstanding of
culture.
It seems to me by that movement in the
art world that is a oppositional art,
in my view,
is dead.
Okay.
It's been this what?
Postmodernism is.
Isn't it pathetic attempt to continue
the old hero as some of the avant garde?
The avant garde was genuinely heroic
from the early 19th century.
Okay.
We,
we're talking about,
you know,
where the core bay,
the realist,
you know,
we're talking about monet and the
impression is people who are genuinely
suffered for their radical ideas and new
innovations and so on.
I going right down to dirt to picasso
and down to a to jackson pollack who
was,
who truly suffered for his art.
It was only after his death.
Okay.
That suddenly the market was created for
abstract art.
Pop art killed the avant garde.
The idea that the avant garde continues.
It's an absolute delusion of the
contemporary art world now,
which feels that it must attack attack,
attack,
challenge.
Okay.
The,
the,
the simplistic belief.
So the toy poodle.
Okay.
It's somehow the arctic.
What?
Excuse me.
Okay.
All right.
From the moment.
Okay.
Andy warhol went through and embraced of
the popular media in britain instead of
having the opposition to it,
the serious artists have had.
That was the end of oppositional art.
Okay,
so we had been going on now for 50
years.
The postmodernism in academe is hand in
hand with the stupidity and infantilism
that masquerades as you know,
as as important art and galleries
everywhere.
This incredible,
incredible,
you know,
it's mechanism oF contemporary art to
pushing things that are,
that are so hopelessly derivative that
with this idea that once again that the
art world,
some houses a period of view of reality,
the authentic leftism is populist.
Okay?
It is based in working class style,
working class language,
working class direct emotion and an
openness and brushing some speech.
Okay.
Not this fanCy,
contorted jargon of this pseudo leftists
of academe who are frauds.
These people,
these people who managed to manage to
rise to the top and ended at berkeley at
harvard and princeton.
Okay.
Have any of These people are radical?
they are career people.
Their corporate types.
Okay.
The who like who succeeded in and they
love the institutional contacts.
They know how to manipulate the
bureaucracy,
which has totally invaded in usurped.
Okay.
The year they have an academe
everywhere.
Okay.
These people are company pl players.
They could have done well in any,
any field and then they,
they love to sit in endless committees.
They love bureaucratic regulation and so
on.
There's not one,
not one leftist.
Okay.
And american academe raised his or her
voice against obscene growth.
Growth of tuition costs which have
bankrupted a whole generation of young
people.
Not,
not one voice.
Okay.
To challenge that.
That invasion by the bureaucrats.
Actual fascist bureaucrats.
Okay.
Well,
if it were for added,
they're like the cancerous.
okay.
There's so many of them because the
faculty have completely lost any power
in american academia.
Okay.
It's us.
It's a scandal.
What has happened and they deserve the
president's servitude that they're in
right now.
Okay.
Because they never protested when I my
first job at bennington college,
1976,
I was there when there was an uprising
by the faculty against encroachment,
by the board of trustees and the
president.
okay.
And it was a huge thing.
It was,
it was,
it was reported on the New York times
and so on.
And we.
And we pushed that precedent out.
Okay.
And,
and there's not been a single uprising
of mankind against,
against encroachment,
by the trustees and by the
administrations and all these decades.
Okay.
Pass them slaves.
Slaves.
They deserve their slavery.
Yup.
I couldn't agree more.
I thought the same thing about
university professors for a long time is
that they get exactly what they deserve
because they never stand up and say no.
And the fact that in the United States,
it's not quite as bad in Canada,
I wouldn't say,
but the fact that the students have been
essentially handed a bill of indentured
servitude here for their student loans
is absolutely beyond comprehension.
You know,
it seems to me that the bureaucracy has
basically conspired to determine how to
pick the pockets of the students' future
earnings.
Right.
And they do that by offering them an
extended adolescence with no quality
control,
something like that.
So it's a real bargain with the devil.
And,
and I told the abandonment of any kind
of education actually in history and
culture,
right?
They haven't going along with it.
That is the transformation into a
cafeteria kind of a menu.
Okay.
We can pick this course or that course
or this course without any kind of
guidance from the university about a
central core curriculum that teaches you
history and chronology and introduces
you to the basics.
Because our professors are prima donnas.
They can only teach and their little
areas.
So we have this total fragmentation.
Okay.
And the,
the,
the great art history survey courses are
being abandoned stedelijk because why?
Because graduate students that are not
trained to see the great narratives or
the network because we are taught now
that narratives are fault.
Okay.
So that's another issue that I'd like to
bring up because one of the things I
cannot say grote is the alliance between
the postmodernists and the neo marxists.
I can't understand the causal
relationship there because the.
Tell me if you disagree with this.
Okay.
Because I'm a psychologist,
not a sociologist,
and so I'm dabbling in things that are
outside of my field of expertise and
there is some danger in that,
but the,
the central postmodernist claim seems to
me that because there's a near incident
number of ways to interpret a complex
set of phenomena which,
which actually happens to be the case
that you can't make a case that any of
those modes of interpretation are
canonical and so if they're not
canonical and if that canonical element
isn't based in some kind of reality than
it serves some other master.
And so The master that it hypothetically
serves for the postmodernists is nothing
but power because that seems to be
everything that they believe it.
They don't believe in competence.
They don't believe in authority.
They don't seem to believe in an
objective world because everything is
language mediated.
So it's an extraordinarily cynical
perspective that that because there's an
infinite number of interpretations,
none of them are canonical.
You can attribute it to everything to
power and dominance.
Okay.
So that,
that seemed like a reasonable summary of
the radical.
It's a radical relativism now,
but the strange thing is despite.
Okay,
and so what goes along with that is the
demolition of grand narratives and so
that would be associated,
for example,
with the rejection of thinkers like
young and Eric Norman,
because of course their foundational
thinkers in relationship to the idea
that there are embodied grand narratives
that's never touched.
But then despite the fact that the grand
narrative is rejected,
there's a neo marxism that's tightly,
tightly allied with postmodernism.
That also seems to shade into this
strange identity.
Politics and I don't.
Two things.
I don't understand the causal
relationship there.
Like the skeptical part of me thinks
that postmodernism was a,
was an intellectual.
It's intellectual camouflage for the
continuation of the kind of pathological
marxism that produced the soviet union
and that has no independent existence as
an intellectual field whatsoever.
But I still can't understand how the
postmodernists to make the no grand
narrative claim,
but then immerse themselves in this
grand narrative without anyone pointing
out the evident contradictions.
Like I don't understand that.
So what do you think about that?
well,
I can only speak about literary and
professors really,
and they seem to me almost universally
in theu ,
s to being very naive or they,
they,
they seemed to know nothing about actual
history,
political science or economics.
It's simply an attitude.
They have an attitude in marxism become
simply a badge by which they telegraph
their,
um,
their solidarity with the working class
that they have nothing to do with.
Right.
I mean they literally nothing but
contempt.
Yes.
And,
and the thing is that the campus left us
are almost notorious for their,
uh,
for their rather snobbish treatment of
staff.
I mean,
they don't,
they don't have any rapport with the
actual working class members of the,
um,
of the infrastructure,
the janitorial,
the janitors,
and even the,
even the secretaries,
there's was kind of high and mighty
aristocracy,
you know,
about.
And they were just,
these are people who,
um,
who have wandered into the english
department and our were products of a
time when,
during the new criticism they were when
history,
but history and psychology had been
excluded.
Me and my ambition.
Okay.
was,
I mean,
I love the new criticism.
okay.
As a,
as a style of textual analysis.
Right?
And,
and the,
and the new criticism had multiple
interpretations.
Okay.
that were possible and that,
and they were encouraged.
In fact,
one of,
one of the great projects was made in
max series 20th century views,
what you had at least books.
I adored them in college.
And it was about Jane Austin or above
emily bronte or about,
um,
words worth and they were collections of
alternate views of the same thing.
The idea that no more,
no alternate views and there was no
relativistic situational kinds of,
of interpreter approach is nonsense.
Okay.
Um,
but the point was we needed to restore
history to literary literary study.
OkAy.
And we needed to add psychology to it
because it was,
was great animus against freud when I
arrived in,
in graduate school.
In fact,
I actually went into the director of
graduate studies and protesting the way
freud and freudian were used as,
as negative terms pay in a sneering way
by that very wasp professors.
So we need to do.
And actually it seemed like we were
moving there in the early 19 seventies
was a great period of psycho biography
about great.
About political figures.
Okay.
And So I thought it's happening in all
of a sudden they'd all got short
circuited by this arrival,
you know,
of,
of post poststructuralism and
postmodernism in the,
in the,
in the 19 seventies.
Right.
Um,
so I,
I,
I feel I'm an old historic assist.
okay.
Now not a new historical.
So I mean I think new stores,
so it was an absolute scam and it's
like,
it's just a way.
It's like tweezers you'd like just,
you pick a little bit of this,
a little bit of that,
a little bit of that you make a little
tiny salad and some of this atomized
thing,
right?
It's supposed to mean something.
It's all can be very superficial,
very cynical,
very distance.
I like,
I am a,
I am the product.
Okay,
of old historicism german philology.
I decide my first choice of a profession
when I was a child.
What was egyptology archeology,
because I'm on.
Everything I ever think about or say is
is related to an enormous time scheme.
Okay.
From from antiquity and indeed from the
stone age,
and that is the problem with these
people.
They're their male educated,
the postmodernist and academic marxists.
Okay.
Are male educated embarrassingly so.
they know nothing before the present for
call.
Okay.
It's absolutely a joke before the
enlightenment.
Okay.
Immune.
Perhaps he might be useful to people to
talk about what happened at after
neoclassicism,
whIch by the way,
he failed to notice a lot of what he was
talking about.
Okay.
Turns out to cb simply the hangover of
neoclassicism.
Okay.
This,
this is how ignorant that man was.
I mean his head was.
He was not talented as a researcher.
He knew absolutely nothing.
Okay,
well,
you know nothing about antiquity.
How can you make any kind of large
structure,
but I'm large mechanism to analyze
western culture without knowing about
classical antiquity.
Okay.
He did not see anything.
He gets some person who had no business
making large theoretical statements
about anything.
Well,
maybe,
maybe part of it is that if you,
if you generate an intelligible doctrine
of radical relativism,
then there is no reason to assume that
there are distinctions between
categories of knowledge or between
different levels of quality of
knowledge.
Right.
so I've seen the same thing in the
psychology departments,
although we have the,
uh,
what would you call it?
The luxury of being bounded at least to
some degree by the empirical method and
by biology,
right?
It's one of the things that keeps most
of the branches of psychology relatively
sane,
you know,
because the real world is actually built
into it to some degree.
But If you accept the postmodernist
claim of radical relativism,
then you completely demolished the idea
that there are quality levels that are
associated with education because
everything becomes the same.
And that seems to me to be a perfectly
reasonable justification for maintaining
ignorance.
You know,
like through co.
I actually found him the most readable
of the lacan.
There are de fuko triad.
You can read fuko.
I read mad distance civilization and a
couple of his other books and I thought
they were painfully obvious.
You know,
the idea that mental disorder is in part
a social construct is self evident to
anybody who has even a smattering of
psychiatric training.
I mean the real narrow medical types
tend to to think of a mental disorder,
let's say as something that might be
purely biological.
They have a peer disease model,
but nobody's who's a sophIsticated
thinker ever thinks that it's a bit
partly because medicine is a brand of
engineering,
not a brand of science because it's
associated with health and the
diagnostic categories are hYbrids
between physiological observation and
sociocultural condition.
Everyone knows that and so when I reaD
madness and civilization,
I thought,
well,
that's not radical.
That's just bloody self evident.
I actually think that he began,
you know,
the entire turn toward a theological
grounding of modern psychology,
social psychology well launcher,
the 19 twenties for example.
You know,
the levels of ignorance of these.
These people moving foco with all
original have not read durkheim.
They've not read mocks of or they've not
read erving goffman.
Okay,
so in other words,
to me,
for everything is the costing of the
estimate because I had read the from
which he was borrowing without
attribution.
so I mean,
again,
I know these people I've met,
um,
in some cases knew them in graduate
school,
people who went onto become these,
these,
these admirers of lack on dairy and I
know what their training was there.
Training was purely within the english
department.
That's all they ever knew.
they never made it any research outside
of that.
Right.
Is the idea for coal is simply this is a
mechanism.
It's like a little tiny kit by which
they can approach everything in culture
and then,
and then the see,
but the contortions of language that
deliberate labyrinthine elitists
language at the same time as pretending
to be a leftist.
Okay.
This is one of the biggest frauds.
every practice.
so I got a story to tell you that you
might like because I've thought a lot
about that use of language,
you know,
because language can be used as
camouflage.
And so here's the story.
I think I got this from robert sapolsky.
So he was talking about zebras and
zebras of course have stripes and
hypothetically that's associated with
camouflage,
but it's not a straightforward
association because zebras are black and
white and they're on the velt along with
the lions,
the lions are camouflaged cause their
grass colored.
But the bloody zebras are black and
white.
You can see them like 15 miles away.
So okay.
So biologists go out to study zebras and
they're like making notes on a zebra and
they watch it.
Then they look down at their notes and
then they look up and they think,
oh no,
no,
no.
Which cbre I was looking at.
So the camouflage is actually against
the herd because the zebras,
a hurt animal,
not an individual.
And so the black and white stripes break
up the animal against the herd so you
can't identify it.
so this was a quandary for the
biologists.
So they did one of two things.
One was drive a jeep up to the,
to the zebra,
heard and use a dab of red paint and dab
the horn.
Should the zebra or tag it with an ear
tag like used for cattle.
The lions would kill it,
so as soon as it became identifiable the
pro,
yes,
the predators could organize their hunt
around that.
Identify about animal.
That's why you know,
there's the old idea that lions and
predators take down the weak animals,
but they don't.
They take down the identifiable animals.
So that's the thing is if you stick your
damn hand handout,
you get picked off by predators and so
one of the things that academics seem to
do is congregate together in heard like
entities and then they share a language,
right,
and the language unites them and also
keeps them as long as they share the
same set of linguistic tools among
themselves that they know that there
isn't anybody in the,
in the codery that's going to attack
them or destabilize the entire herd.
And that seems to me to account for that
Impenetrable use of language.
it's,
it's group protection strategy and it
has absolutely nothing to do with the
search for.
It's the search for security within a
system and not the desire to expand the
system.
Right.
Not
federal,
but intimate is blatantly careerist
because they made.
It was,
it was about advancement and with also
about the claim that somehow they have
special expertise.
This is a special technical language.
No one else can understand it.
Only only weekend,
but what's absurd about it absolutely
ludicrous that these people,
these,
these american academics are imitating
the contorted language of french at the
translations from the french.
Okay.
When that call is translated into,
into english,
right?
There's a contortion there.
okay.
Well,
here's what he was trying to do in
french was to break up.
Okay.
The neoclassical formulations that
descended from racine,
there was something that was going on.
There was a sabotage of the french
language going on that was necessary in
France.
Not necessarily in english.
We have this long tradition of poetry.
Going back to the shakespeare and
chaucer.
We have,
we have our own language,
but far more vItal than that than the
french.
The french constrain their language all
the time.
The absurdity in the amateur is okay of
american academics trying to imitate.
Okay.
A translation of like hall,
okay,
we doing something in France that is
absolutely not necessary and indeed
wrong to be doing in english,
but the other,
the other cynical abandonment.
Okay.
Have the great tradition of,
of,
of uh,
of the english departments.
And I,
I felt that the true radicalism was not
about adding on other departments.
Okay.
So we have african american studies and
you know,
and,
and women's studies and so on.
The true radicalism would have been to
shatter the departmental structure.
That's what I wanted.
I feel that was the authentic
revolutionary 19,
67 to do,
right.
Don't look to them to blend all the
literature,
study saudis together.
Okay.
Just to make easIer to make an
interdisciplinary kind of organization
or you know,
closer to the british model where a
person can pursue related subjects,
overlapping subjects.
These,
these,
these departmental models.
Okay.
Are,
were,
were to me,
totalitarian to begin with.
Okay.
separating language into fiefdoms and,
and,
and what,
what the stitch to create a english
women's studies department.
Absolutely.
Out of the air.
Just snap your fingers and create
women's studies.
The english department had taken a
century to develop.
Okay.
And was.
It was a huge argument.
Okay.
Within.
Within it.
Right.
And all of a sudden to create.
Okay.
It department where they politicize
agenda from the start.
Okay.
By people without any training
whatsoever in that field.
And what should be the.
What should be the parameters of the
fIeld,
which would be the requirements of that
feel.
How about biology?
Okay.
If you're going to be discussing gender,
that should have been a number one
requirement.
Okay.
as part of any witness studies
department or program.
But no,
it was all hands off.
it was just the administrators wanted to
solve a public relations problem.
They had a situation with very few women
faculty nationwide at a time when the
women's movement had,
had just started up that spotlight of
attention was,
was on them.
They want,
they needed women faculty fast.
They need to do with the women's subject
on the agenda fast.
Right.
So they just start let there be women's
studies.
Okay.
And now we'll just hire some women.
It usually from english departments,
you know,
here and there and we'll just throw them
together.
You invent it,
you say what it is,
so that's why women's that has got
frozen at certain point of the ideology
of the early 19 seventies.
I was already in revolt from it.
Okay.
I went,
I was a precursor in terms of my
endorsement of feminists some before it,
before even now is created.
Right.
But I couldn't.
I couldn't even have a conversation with
any of these women.
They were hysterical about this subject
of biology.
they knew nothing about hormones and I.
I mean I,
I,
I probably got in fist fights over this.
They went.
People were so convinced that biology
had nothing whatsoever to do with gender
differences.
That also seems to me to be related to
the postmodern emphasis on power because
there's a,
there's something terrible underground
going on there that is an.
I think this is the sort of thing that
was reflected in the soviet union to,
in the,
especially in the twenties when there
was this idea of radical idea that you
could remake human beings entirely,
right?
Because they have no essential nature,
and so if your fundamental hypothesis is
that nothing exists except power and you
believe that,
then that also gives you the right in
some sense to exercise your power at the
creation of the kind of humanity that
your utopian vision envisioned.
Then that has no fat and that also seems
to me to justify the postmodern
insistence that everything is only a
linguistic construct.
It again gOes down to the notion of
power,
which dera done food co and luck tower,
so bloody obsessed with.
and so,
and it seems to me what they're trying
to do is to,
uh,
to take all the potential power for the
creation of human beings to themselves
without any bounding conditions
whatsoever.
RIght?
There's no history,
there's no biology,
there's,
and,
and everything is a fluid culture that
can be manipulated at will.
and so I,
in Canada,
there are terrible arguments right now
about biological essentialism,
let's say.
And one of the things that happened,
which was something I objected to
precisely a year ago,
is that the social constructionist view
of human identity.
He has been built now into canadian law.
So there's an insistence that biological
sex,
gender identity,
gender expression and sexual proclivity
very independently with no causal
relationship between any of the levels.
And so that's In the law and not only is
it in the law,
it's being taught everywhere,
it's being taught in the armed forces,
it's being taught in the police,
it's being taught to the elementary
school kids and the junior high school
kids and underneath it all,
I see this terrible striving for
arbitrary power that's associated with
this crazy utopianism and,
and,
but I still don't exactly understand it.
I don't like,
I don't understand that.
What seems to be the hatred that
motivates it that you see bubbling up,
for example,
in identity politics and,
and in the desire to do nothing but
let's say demolish the patriarchy.
It kinda reminds me,
and this is something else I wanted to
talk to you about,
you know,
in your,
you're an admirer of Eric Norman and
have girl young.
Yeah.
And that's the human connection is
really interesting because I think he's
a bloody genius.
I really liked the great mother is a
great book and it really a great
warning.
That book and also the orIgins and
history of consciousness is one of the
most influential book.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but that's so interesting.
I read an essay that you wrote or I
don't remember
again at
the nyu.
Yes,
yes.
It's always been staggering to me that
that book hasn't had the impact that it
should have had.
I mean young himself in the preface to
that book wrote that that was the book
that he wished that he would have
written.
It's very much associated with young
symbols of transformation and it was a
major influence on my book maps of
meaning,
which was an attempt to outline the
universal archetypes that are portrayed
in the kind of religious structures that
you,
that you put forward,
but the thing that I really see
happening,
and you can tell me what you think about
this and in norman's book consciousness,
which is masculine symbolically
masculine for a variety of reasons is,
is viewed as rising up against the
countervailing force of tragedy from an
underlying feminine,
symbolically feminine unconsciousness.
Right.
and it's something that can always be
pulled back into that unconsciousness
that would be the microcosm of that
would be the friday and eatable mother
femineity dynamic where the mother was
so over protective and all encompassing
that she interferes with the development
of the competence,
not only of her sons,
but also of her daughters,
of her children in general.
And it seems to me that that's the
dynamic that's being played out in our
society right now is that there's this
and it's,
it's related in some way that I don't
understand to this,
to this insistence that all forms of
masculine authority or nothing by
tyrannical power.
So The symbolic representation is
tyrannical father with no appreciation
for the benevolent father and benevolent
mother with no appreciation whatsoever
for the tyrannical mother.
Right?
And that's that.
And because I thought of videology as
fragmentary mythologies,
that's where they get their archetype
will in psychological power,
right?
And so on and balanced representation.
You have the terrible mother and the
great mother as,
as norman laid out so nicely and you
have the terrible father and the great
father.
So that's the fact that culture mangles
you have to death well,
it's also promoting you and developing
you.
You have to see that as balanced and
then you have the heroic and adversarial
individual.
But in the postmodern world,
and this seems to be something that's
increasingly seeping out into the
culture at large,
you have nothing but the tyrannical
father,
nothing but the destructive force of
masculine consciousness and nothing but
the benevolent,
benevolent great mother and it's an,
it's an appalling ideology and it seems
to me that it's sucking the vitality
once,
which is exactly what you would expect
symbolically.
It's sucking the vitality of our
culture.
You see that with the increasing
demolition of,
of young men,
um,
and not only young men in terms of their
academic performance,
which like they're falling way behind in
elementary school way behind in junior
high and bailing out of the universities
like mad.
And so,
and I,
I,
well the public school education,
it's become completely permeated by this
kind of anti male propaganda.
I mean,
and to me,
public schools,
I just a form of imprisonment,
you know,
right now they are particularly
destructive to young men who have a lot
of physical energy,
right?
Uh,
yet now I identify as transgender gay
mike myself,
but I do not,
I do not require the entire world to
alter itself okay.
To,
to fit my particular in the self image.
I do believe in the power of hormones.
I believe that men exist and women
exists and are biologically different.
I think that I think there is no cure
for the cultural ills right now except
if men start standing up and demanding
that they be respected as men again.
Okay.
So I goT a question about that.
So,
so one of the things we did a research
project year ago,
trying to figure out if there was such a
thing as political correctness from a
psychometric perspective to find out is
there the loose aggregation of beliefs
actually clumped together statistically.
And we actually fOund two factors which
I won't go into,
but then we looked at things that
predicted adherence to that,
that a politically correct creed.
And there were a cOuple that were
surprising.
One was being female was a predictor,
the personality attributes associated
with femininity,
so that would be agreeableness and
higher levels of negative emotion.
We're also both independent predictors
but so were symptoms of personality
disorder,
which I thought was really important
because part of what I see happening is
that like I think that women whose
relationship with men have,
has been seriously pathologized,
cannot distinguish between male
authority and competence and male
tyrannical power,
like they failed to differentiate
because all they see is the oppressive
mail.
And then they may have had experiences
that,
um,
their experiences with men might've been
rough enough so that,
that differentiation never occurred
because it has to occur and you have to
have a lot of experience with men and
good men do before that will occur.
BuT it seems to me that we're also
increasingly dominated by a view of
masculinity that's mostly characteristic
of women who have terrible personality
disorders and who are unable to have
healthy relationships with men.
Now.
But here's the problem,
you know,
this is something my wife has pointed
out to.
She said,
well,
men are going to have to stand up for
themselves,
but here's the problem.
I know how to stand up to a man who's,
who's,
uh,
unfairly trespassed against me.
And the reason I know that is because
the parameters for my resistance are
quite well defined,
which is we talk,
we argue,
we push,
and then it becomes physical,
right?
Like if,
if we move beyond the boundaries of
civil discourse,
we know what the next step is.
Okay.
THat's forbidden in,
in discourse with women.
Right?
And so I don't think that men can
control crazy women.
I don't think.
I really don't believe that.
I think that they have to throw their
hands up in,
in,
in what,
in not even disbelief.
It's that the cultural,
there's no step forward that you can
take under those circumstances because
if the man is offensive enough and crazy
enough,
the reaction becomes physical right
away.
Or at least the threat is there.
And when men are talking to each other
in any serious manner,
that underlying thread of physicality is
always there,
especially if it's a real conversation,
keeps the things civil arts to some
degree,
you know,
if you're talking to a man who wouldn't
fight with you under any circumstances
whatsoever,
then you're talking to someone to whom
you have absolutely no respect,
but I can't see any way.
For example,
there's a,
there's a woman in in toronto who's been
organizing this movement,
let's say against me and some other
people who are going to do a free speech
event and she managed to organize quite
effectively and she's quite ofensive you
might say.
She compared us to nazis,
for example,
which,
you know,
publicly using the swastika,
which wasn't really something I was all
that fond of.
But I,
I'm defenseless against that kind of
female insanity because the techniques
that I would use against a man who was
employing those tactics are forbidden to
me.
So I don't know.
Like it seems to me that it isn't men
that have to stand up and say enough of
this,
even though that is what they should do.
It seems to me that it's same women who
have to stand up against their crazy
sisters and say,
look,
enough of that enough man hating enough
pathology,
enough bringing disgrace on us as a,
as a gender,
but the problem there and then they'll
stop my little tirade is that most of
the women I know who are saying are busy
doing saying things right.
They're all,
they have their career,
they have their family,
they're quite occupied and they don't
seem to have the time or maybe even the
interest to go after their,
their crazy harpy sisters and so I don't
see any regulating force for that,
that terrible femininity and it seems to
me to be invading the culture and
undermining the masculine power of the
culture in a way that's,
I think fatal.
I really do believe
I too.
I too believe that these are symptomatic
of the decline of western culture and,
and,
and it will just go down flat.
I don't think people realize that,
you know,
masculinity is still exists.
okay.
In the world as a code among jihadist.
Okay.
And,
and when you have Passionate
masculinity,
right?
Circling the borders like the hawaiians
and the vandals during the roman empire,
that that's what I see.
I see this culture rotting from within.
Okay.
And and does all link itself literally
now my,
I have an overview of why we're having
these problems and if it comes from the
fact that I'm the product of an
immigrant family.
All four of my grandparents and my
mother were born in Italy,
so I remember from my earliest years in
this factory town in upstate New York
where the y,
but my relatives came to work in the
shoe factory.
I can remember still okay.
They,
the life of the agrarian era.
Okay.
Which,
which,
which for most of human history or the
agrarian era where there was the world
of men and the world of women and they
sex has had very little to do with each
other.
Each had power and status and its own
realm.
Right?
And they.
And they laughed at each other in.
In essence,
the way the women had enormous power.
In Fact,
the old women ruled not the young
beautiful woman like today,
but the,
the older you were,
the more you had control over our
everyone,
including the mating and marriage.
Um,
you know,
there were no doctors so that you had
the,
the old women were like midwives and
knew all the ins and outs of this and
inherited knowledge about pregnancy and
all these other things.
Right?
I can remember this.
And,
and the joy that women had with each
other all day long.
Okay.
Cooking with each other,
you know,
a companions to each other.
Talking,
conversing.
My mother remembered as a small child in
Italy when it was time to do the
laundry,
they would take the laundry up the
mountain,
up the hill to the fountain you'll ago.
Okay.
And,
and do it by hand.
They would sing,
they would pick nick and so on.
Right?
And we get a glimpse of that in the
odyssey when odysseus is,
is,
is thrown up naked on the shores of asia
and,
and he hears the sound of women,
young women laughing and singing.
And it's nausicaa the princess bringing
the women to do the laundry where he's
exactly the same thing.
Right?
so there was a,
each,
each gender had its own hierarchy,
its own values,
own way of talking.
And the sexist rarely intersected.
Like I can remember in my childhood on a
holiday.
TypiCal,
it could be christmas,
it could be a thanksgiving,
whatever.
All the women would be cooking all day
long.
Everyone would sit down to eat.
Okay.
And then after that,
okay.
The women who retire unmasked to the
kitchen and the men would go,
I would,
I would look at the window and see all
the men.
The men would be all outside,
usually gather around the car.
Okay.
Then a time when cars didn't work as
well as they do today with the hood up.
Okay.
And the men would be standing with their
hands on their hips like that.
Everyone's staring at the engine.
And I went,
yeah.
That's how I learned.
Okay.
Men where we refreshing themselves by
studying something technical and
mechanical after being with women.
Okay.
You know,
for during the dinner.
Okay.
And so,
so,
so all of these problems of today are
the direCt consequence of women's
emancipation and freedom from housework,
thanks to capitalism,
okay?
Which made it possible for women to have
jobs outside the home for the very first
time in the 19th century,
no longer to be dependent on a husband
or father or brother,
right?
And so this great,
great thing that's happened to us,
allowing us to be totally self
supporting independent agents has
produced all this animosity about making
too many men and women because the
women,
women feel unhappy.
Women Today,
wherever I go,
whether it's Italy or Brazil or england
or America or toronto,
okay?
The,
the,
the upper middle class professional
women are unhappy,
miserable they want and they don't know
what,
why they're unhappy.
They want to blame it on men.
The men must change.
Men must become more like women know
that is the wrong way to go.
Okay?
It's when men are men and understand
themselves as men are secure as men,
then you are going to be happier.
Well,
there's nothing more dangerous than a
weak man.
Absolutely.
Okay.
And especially all these quislings okay.
Spouting feminist rhetoric,
I hear that.
Okay.
I mean it makes me sick,
but here's the point.
Men and women have never worked side by
side ever.
Maybe under farms.
okay.
When you were like maybe one person in
the potato fields,
the other ones over here in the.
During the tOmatoes or whatever.
Okay.
You,
you,
you had,
you had familieS working,
working side by side,
exhaust with each other.
no time to have it in any of this.
It was a collaborative effort on,
on forums and so on.
Never in all of human history have men
and women been working side by side and
women are now the pressure about silicon
valley.
There are also sexist.
They don't allow women in and so on.
The men are being men in silicOn valley
and the women,
the engineers and the women are
demanding that,
oh,
this is terrible.
You're being say maybe the sexes.
Okay.
HAve their own particular form of
rhetoric.
Their own particular form of identity.
Okay.
Maybe.
We need to re,
re,
re examine.
Okay.
This business about your,
the mic.
Maybe we have to perhaps except some
degree of tension and conflict between
the sexes.
Okay.
In a work environment,
I don't mean harassment.
I'm sorry.
I'm talking about women feeling
disrespected now.
Somehow they their opinions when they
express them.
Okay.
Are not taken seriously or or the.
Or even hillary clinton is complaining.
Oh,
when a woman writes something online,
she's attacked immediately so.
Well,
everyone's attacked online.
What are you talking about?
The world is tough.
The world is competitive.
Okay.
Identity is hold.
By conflict,
the idea that there should be no
conflict,
that we have to be in this bath at
probation and you know,
we just,
we just devour it.
That's
right.
It's absolutely infant title in a
minute.
Okay,
so a couple of things there.
Well,
the first thing is,
is that the,
the agreeableness trait that divides men
and women most.
There's three things that divide women
and men most particularly from the
psychometric perspective.
One is that women are more agreeable
than men,
and so that seems to be the primary
maternal dimension as far as I can tell
them.
It's associated with a desire to avoid
conflict,
but it's associated with interpersonal
closeness,
compassion,
politeness.
Women are reliably higher than men,
especially in the scandinavian countries
and in the countries where
egalitarianism has progressed the
farthest,
so that's where the difference is.
Maximize,
which is one of the things james demore
poInted out quite correctly and his
infamous google memo,
okay,
women are hIgher in negative emotion,
so that's anxiety and emotional pain,
not that difference is approximately the
same size and again that maximizes in
egalitarian societies which is extremely
interesting and then the biggest
difference is the difference in
interests between people and things and
so women are more interested in people
and men are more interested in things
which goes along quite nicely with your
car anecdote,
but the thing about men interacting with
men again,
is that it isn't that they respect each
other's viewpoints.
That's not exactly right.
What happens with a man,
and I know a lot of men that I would
regard as as remarkably tough people for
one reason or another and everything you
do with them as a form of combat,
like if you want your viewpoint taken
seriously,
often you have to yell them down and
like they're not going to stop talking
unless you start talking over them.
You know,
and it's not like manner automatically
giving respect to other men because that
just doesn't happen.
Instead,
the combat is there and it's expected
and one of the problems,
and so this is part of the reason why I
think men are being out of so much of
academia and and maybe the academic
world in general and maybe the world in
general,
is that men actually don't have any idea
how to compete with women.
Because the problem is,
is that if you unleash yourself
completely,
then you're an absolute bully.
And there's no doubt about that.
Because if men unleash themselves on
other men,
that can be pretty goddamn brutal.
Especially for the men that are really
tough.
and so that just doesn't happen with
women.
But.
So you can't unleash yourself completely
if you,
when you're a bully,
if you lose while you're just bloody
pathetic.
So how the hell are you supposed to play
a game like that,
you know?
So I've worked with lots of women in law
firms in Canada for example,
and and high achieving women,
like really remarkable people I would
say.
And they're often nonplussed I would say
by the attitude of the man in the law
firm because they would like to see
everyone pulling together because
they're all part of the same team,
whereas the manner like at each other's
throats in an,
in a cooperative way because they want
the law firm to succeed,
but they want to be the person who's at
the top of the success hierarchy.
Right?
So,
and that,
that doesn't jive well with the more
competitive or cooperative ethos.
That's part and parcel of agreeableness.
And so we don't really have any idea how
to integrate male and female dominance.
Exactly.
That's exactly right.
This is why I love this show.
Real housewives and I,
which,
which is scorings.
And jusT say,
just last night I was watching one
episode right where the women were at
each other.
Okay.
At a party and not in,
in,
in recounting,
but I said this to you,
but you said this to me and the men got.
We got together there and said,
well,
this is the way they communicate with
each other and innocent and that,
you know,
men,
okay,
just we'll have a fistfight and wheel
him in 10 minutes later we're going to
have a beer at the bar next to each
other and so on.
And I have observed that.
My mind,
my daughter,
my daughter used to be really irritated
about that because she,
she,
like most people was the target of
feminine,
a conspiratorial bullying at one.
She's no pushover.
My daughter.
so this wasn't like this was a continual
thing or that she didn't know what to do
about it,
but she used to observe these girls
conspiring against her and then black
getting your name on on facebook,
which is part of it,
part and parcel of the typical female
bullying routine,
which is often reputation demolition,
right?
That there's a good literature on that.
And Then she'd watched what would happen
if my brother or my son would have a
dispute with his friends,
you know,
and maybe they were drinking and there
was a dispute they'd have a fight and
then the next day they were friends
again.
And that's another thing that's strange
is that men have a way of bringing a
conflict to a head and resolving it
right.
And that it isn't obvious to me that
Women have that same,
perhaps you might call it a luxury,
but it's also the case that men know
what to do when they get into a conflict
with a woman because what the hell are
you supposed to do?
You know,
mostly what you're supposed to do is
avoid it.
And
well,
I think um,
you know,
I don't know whether this crosses into
other countries,
but that there was a certain kind of
taunting and teasing that men and boys
do with each other that toughens them.
Okay.
And,
and where they don't,
they don't take things seriously.
But a girl feelings become extremely
hurt if you hear something like that.
It goes very tough,
you know,
again,
like sarcastic against her.
so I mean,
I do feel that there are profound
differences between the sexes and in
terms of emotions,
in terms of communication patterns.
I know my father used to say that he
could never follow women's can
conversations.
He said he said women don't even finish
the finish sentences that with the women
understand immediately what the other
woman is saying.
Okay.
Uh,
and um,
the way the women tend to be more
interested in or haven't been
traditionally more interested in soap
operas,
it's not just the women who were home
without jobs is that I honestly,
I believe that soap opera does reflect,
does mirror the way women talk to each
other.
There's these communication patterns and
then built up through women,
the world of women.
Okay.
Which was it made sense.
There was a division of labor.
Okay.
It wasn't sexism against women that
there was a division of labor.
The men went off to hunt and did the
dangerous thing.
The women stayed around the heart
because you had pregnant women,
nursing women,
older women.
Okay.
They were cooking and so on.
So I feel that these communication
patterns that we're talking about have
been built up over the centuries and the
men had to toughen each other.
Okay.
Do want to go out in the hunting part is
a native americans,
you know,
it would be gone for two weeks and it
was when the temperature was below zero
and many of didn't die.
Okay.
Yeah.
The idea that somehow in any kind of
separation of the sexes are different
spheres of the sexes is inherently
sexist power dynamic.
The answer to all of this.
Okay.
Then everything that we're talking
about.
Okay.
Is education into early history.
And until you are,
until people understand the stone age,
but nomadic period,
the agrarian era and ended up and how
culture,
how civilization built up.
Okay.
In mesopotamia,
the great irrigation projects,
or in orange Egypt where you head for
the first centralized government
authority became necessary.
Okay.
To master these needs and you had a
situation where an environmentally,
uh,
you know,
a difficult situation like the deserts
of mesopotamia or,
or the,
the peculiar character of,
of Egypt and geography where you can
only have a little tiny,
tiny,
fertile line along the edges of denial.
OkAy.
Otherwise,
desert landscape.
So this civilization and authority.
Okay.
Right.
I as not necessarily about power
grabbing,
but about organization to achieve
something for the good of the people as
a whole.
Well,
that's exactly the symbolism of the
great for reducing
hierarchy to,
to power and selfish power.
Okay.
Is it is utterly naive.
It's ignorant,
right?
So I say education to be totally
reconstituted,
including public education to be getting
the most distant past it,
so that.
So our young people today who know
nothing about how the,
how the world was created that they
inhabit,
okay.
Can understand,
okay,
what marvelous technological paradise
they live in.
And it's the product of capitalism as
the productive of individual innovation
is the most of,
is the project will have a western
tradition that everyone wants to trash
now is there,
if you be getting the past and show it
also talk about war because the war is
the one thing that wakes people up.
Okay.
As we see wars,
wars,
the reality principle,
my father and all five of my uncles went
to world war two.
My father was part of the force that I
landed in Japan.
Okay.
Uh,
as a paratrooper,
um,
you know,
at the time of the japanese surrender
and,
and a couple uncles got shot up and so
on,
when you have the reality of war,
when people see the reality of the
horrors of war,
berlin burned to a crisp and,
and so on.
Starvation.
Okay?
Then you understand,
okay,
there's a marvelous mechanism that
brings water,
you know,
to,
to the,
to the kitchen.
And when you flip on a light looked
lately,
electric,
electricity.
No.
For me,
like I suppose it's because I have
somewhat of a depressive temperament.
I mean,
one Thing that staggers me on a
consistent basis is the fact that
anything ever works.
I mean because it's so unlikely you
know,
to,
to be in a situation where our
electronic communications work,
where our,
where our electric grid works and it
works all the time,
right?
It works a hundred percent of the time
and the reason for that is that there
are mostly men out there who are
breaking themselves into pieces
repairing this thing which just falls
apart all the time.
I said this in the month debate,
okay?
In toronto several years ago,
I said that there's the invisible at all
these,
you know,
these elitist professors,
sneering at men.
It's men who are maintaining everything
around us and anything is an invisible
army.
Which feminist don't notice.
Nothing would work
or regarded regarded as impressive,
which was,
you know,
like a professor is someone who's
standing on a hill surrounded by a wall
which is surrounded by another wall
which is surrounded by another wall.
Like it's walls all the way down.
Who stands uP there and says,
I am brave and independent.
It's like you've got this protected area
that's so unlikely.
It's so absolutely unlikely,
and the fact that people aren't on their
knees in gratitude all the time for the
fact that we have central heating and
air conditioning and and pure water and
reliable food,
it's just,
it's so.
It is.
It's absolutely unbelievable and
people used to die for then the water
supply was contaminated with cholera for
heaven's sakes,
right?
People don't understand,
okay.
That kept clean water,
fresh milk,
fresh orange juice,
all of these things,
these mro,
nolan at the time,
all the time,
if that western culture is heading,
become because we are so dependent on
this invisible infrastructure where a
heading for an absolute catastrophe when
hottest,
figure out how to paralyze the power
grid,
the entire culture will be be chaotic.
You'll have mobs in the street.
Okay,
and within three days.
wIndow.
So suddenly the food supply is
interrupted and there's no light.
There's no,
no way to communicate.
There'll be like a robert.
I mean that.
That is the way western culture is going
to collapse.
Okay?
And it won't take much because we are so
interconnected and now we are so it's
so.
It's so dependent on communications and
computers to the the I've,
I've,
I used to predict for years there'll be
an asteroid hitting there enough another
the solar flares work.
So back in.
This happens about once every century,
so back about 18,
80,
and I don't remember the exact year.
There was a significant enough solar
flare,
so that produces a electromagnetic
pulse,
like a hydrogen bomb because the sun is
a hydrogen bomb and electromagnetic
pulse will emerge from the sun and wave
across the earth and it produces huge
spikes in electrical electrical curd
along anything that's electronic and
it'll burn them out.
It led it lid telegraph operators on
fire in the 18 hundreds and one of those
things took out the quebec power grid in
1985 and knocked out the whole northeast
corridor.
And so they figure those things are
about one in new century event.
But those single.
I have my brother in law who's a very
smart guy.
He designed the chip and the iphone.
We were talking about political issues
the last time I went and saw him in san
francisco and his notion was that all
that the government should be doing
right now is stress testing our
infrastructure the same way they stress
test the banks because we're so full of
these single points of failure that.
And I think you're absolutely right.
Luckily we've been,
um,
what would you call,
invaded by stupid terrorists instead of
smart terrorists because it's a smart
terrorists could do an unbelievable
amount of damage in a very short period
of time.
So when it's just god's good graces
that,
that hasn't happened yet.
And so,
and then what will happen is that if the
men,
okay,
the men will reconstruct civilization
while the women cower in the houses and
they have the men go out and do all the
dirty work.
That's what's going to happen again.
only men will,
will bring civilization back again.
So what.
Okay.
So now a couple of things.
So the,
the universities,
I mean I've proposed,
although it's something that's probably
beyond my power that what should happen
is that the universities,
the real content of the universities
should be stolen back from the
universities because they're not making
use of their intellectual property and
that something should be started online
that would constitute a genuine
university.
The problem is the accreditation issue,
but I don't think that's a solvable
problem.
But do you see like all these people who
have these postmodern neil marxist
agendas are completely embedded inside
the unit
and the point is over the,
over the last 25 years,
I have received constant mail from
people dropping out of the graduate
school.
So I and r or giving up altogether on
any idea of being a college professor
because what's happened is that the most
talent than an independent thinking
people have avoided in the school.
So we are now who we have on the
compliant.
The survival.
Okay.
The people who are currently in the
university and,
and hiring their successors.
Okay.
Are male educated themselves.
I mean,
I,
I went on the first letters I received
and the early 19 nineties,
I'll never forget it,
it was from a woman who was now a
painting houses in Missouri and said she
had been part of the comparative
literature or a graduate program at,
uh,
at,
you know,
at berkeley and that she finally had to
drop out because she said every time she
would express enthusiasm for what they
were reading,
the qa,
the people looked at her as if she had
somehow encouraging an offense in other,
in other words,
enthusiasm for art or new,
the very things you need as a teacher in
the classroom.
Okay.
We're being trained out
your undergrad.
If you respect art and literature,
that means that you implicitly accept a
hierarchy of quality.
Right.
And not to,
of course contradicts the fundamental
tenants of the postmodern doctrine,
which is that there are no hierarchies
of quality.
And you know,
when you.
You talked a little bit earlier about
the,
the idea that you referred again to the
idea that everything is associated with
power and that's,
that's the thing that I can't.
That's the thing that I can't help but
associate with,
with the kind of personality pathology,
like you know from a psychometric
perspective,
the best predictors of longterm success
in our society,
our intelligence iq,
which you can measure very accurately
and trait conscientiousness,
which actually is a real testament to
the culture,
right?
Because what you hope is that the smart
people who work hard are the people who
advance it.
Not.
It isn't like they deserve it.
Exactly.
That isn't what I mean.
It's that if the culture is harnessing
the productive power of individuals
properly,
then it should differentially reward
people who are smart and conscientious
because they're going to do a bunch of
really interesting work for the rest of
us and that that's very well
established.
Finding it's,
it's as good as any finding in the
social sciences,
but despite that and despite the fact
that everything works,
which is a god damn miracle of sorts,
there is this consistent story that we
live in a patriarchy,
that it's only oppressive,
that it's done nothing but oppressed
women since the beginning of time,
which is also something that just
boggles my mind.
You know,
like I knew
that I have sacrificed for our women and
children cleaner their lives.
Okay.
For thousands of years,
you know that and yes,
there's been brutality,
but the battalion and the minority.
Okay.
Yes.
This,
this sick.
The portrayal of human history is
nothing but male oppression and female
victim manage.
Okay.
This is a way to permanently ensure the
infantilization of women.
Absolutely.
Yes.
Well,
and you can even make the case from a
purely logical perspective.
So.
So here's an interesting,
here's an interesting thought.
So most of the people who abuse their
children were abused as children,
but most of the people who were abused
as children don't abuse their children.
Right?
So if you look at the population of
abusers,
they were all abused.
So you can say abuse causes abuse,
but that's,
that's not a good idea because you have
a specific sample there,
right?
It's not a sample.
What happens is that abuse dampens out
over the centuries.
It doesn't propagate itself.
And that's obvious because if there was,
if,
if the hypothesis of essential men,
male tyranny was true,
it would spread exponentially through
the population.
And like three generations and there
wouldn't be an exception at all.
And so what happens is even when there
is a tilt towards tyranny,
let's say in the family or even in the
society that regresses back to something
that's far more benign,
very,
very rapidly.
You see this so
hit me when one of the biggest
unexamined issues is the transition from
the great extended family of old okay
into the nuclear family.
And I do feel that freud is the best
analyst of the particular,
particular kind of claustrophobic cell
of,
of the modern nuclear family.
It could be the human being,
it could be that human beings were never
intended.
Okay.
It should be to be trapped in a house,
just what their parents and their
extended families.
But you had your aunts and you know,
in grandparents and cousins,
all of whom helped form your identity.
Okay.
So what,
what,
what one's identity with one member of a
community rather than in just like hot
house environment.
So I think a lot of current issues,
including the sudden spate of
transgender claims and so on,
that a lot of these things are coming
from,
um,
unstable of in cell.
It's a truly a prison cell of a nuclear
family.
Two parents perhaps cannot give all the
knowledge of life okay to,
to the young.
And so I,
I think there are all kinds of,
of um,
sexual issues,
you know,
in that are generated by.
But with the psychology today is a,
is now I would simply a matter of a
practical matter and people come in,
uh,
you know,
the psychologist in the United States
deals with your,
your present problem.
Let's not go into the distant past,
okay,
let's just deal with our president
problem which are,
which obviously we have forms of
communication we need to like fix this
and then you'll be fine.
As a consequence,
there's a complete absence of any kind
of analysis of your experiences as a
child with your parents,
with,
with your siblings and so on.
How that might relate to your current
sexual identity issues,
whether it's transgender,
whether it's homosexuality,
it has impact.
You cannot possibly ask you about any
genesis of homosexuality today because
that is automatically defined as
homophobic.
Well,
excuse me,
every single as an openly gay person
myself,
I every gay person I know.
Okay.
There is some story.
There seems to be in childhood.
Not only that,
there's a string similarity of the
storylines of all of my friends who are
gay.
There's the same pattern that had to do
with blurred borderlines,
be between a son and his mother and so
on.
I'm not blaming the mother.
Okay.
I'm not blaming the mother at all.
What I.
What I see as a dynamic going on the
bourgeois house,
so the nuclear family where you had
sometimes a distant father.
Okay.
A father who was present but it but not
really engaged,
and a mother who,
who,
who made the.
Her companion is some way off in the
mother has great imagination and flare
and they had a shared thing and I mean
the idea that sexuality has nothing,
whatever to do.
Okay with your family.
Life is not good.
I grow.
It's also completely well.
That's another thing,
and I got a lot of trouble in Canada for
my opposition to bill [inaudible],
which was a bill that had to do with
transgender rights and I didn't really
give a damn about the transgender right
issue that had nothing to do with it.
What bothered me was that there was an
issue of Compelled speech because you
were required by the ontario human
rights commission to use the pronouns
that of the person's choice.
Right.
Otherwise,
absolutely our wellbeing.
That is absolutelY intolerable.
You know,
I,
I have said,
I said years ago,
okay,
that my book sexual persona,
which was like a 700 page book,
I said,
that is the biggest sex change in
history because I okay with my
transgender issues all don't look to the
magnificent construction of english.
Okay.
It was the english language.
That I seized on the game,
my identity and my power as a person.
Right.
And therefore any intrusion into
english.
Someone told me how to use english.
that's great gift.
Okay.
To me,
this is absolutely obscene and evil
government to try to dictate to us how
we're going to use this,
this magnificent instrument of english.
Yes,
absolutely.
And that was for me the breaking point
because I believe well and I think that
that's associated with the idea of the
logos in the west,
you know,
because that's a deep mythological idea
that the logos is the thing that brings
order out of chaos through communicative
speech and that that's tightly aligned
with your soul.
And I don't care if You're an atheist or
a believer,
it doesn't matter.
It's still the right language and that
no one has any right whatsoever under
any circumstances to trespass against
that.
And so,
but that's okay because that's law in
Canada now and so,
but okay.
So now back to your.
Let's see,
you were making a point about mine.
I know we wouldn't grow so just because
it's,
it's interesting to look at these things
from obviously from multiple
perspectives,
which is another thing the ideologues
don't do,
rIght?
Because for them everything is one cause
there's one.
That's how you can tell when you're
dealing with someone who's ideologically
possessed is they make everything
attributable to a single cause like
power.
So,
but so one of the things that's happened
with the nuclear family that's quite
interesting too,
is that parents are older and they and
they have fewer children.
So you could imagine that that hot house
environment in some sense as being
exaggerated for a bunch of reasons,
one is,
well your child is a lot more valuable
to you if you're older and you only have
one or two right,
because you're not going to get another
chance.
That's first of all,
you might've had some trouble having the
child to begin with and you're not gonna
get another chance.
so you've got all your eggs are in one
basket,
so to speak.
And then of course children don't have
the number of siblings they used to
have.
And one of the things that's really
useful about having siblings is that
they,
you in your place,
right?
They,
their primary socialization agents.
And I mean,
that can be brutal and that's reflected
say in the story of cain and abel,
you know,
that that internal household dynamic
with siblings can be,
can really become murderous and that has
to be kept under control.
But I think the,
the hothouse flower person who's,
who's incapable of tolerating any jobs
or any or any testing,
any dominance hierarchy,
testing of the sort that you said that
men do,
part of that's the consequence of being
raised by older parents who have excess
resources,
who have no siblings because the child
is then of course special and that
specialness.
Well there,
there seems to be an inverse
relationship between that specialness
that's protected and the person's
robustness and resilience.
And so,
and then that's caught into or not
caught in too.
That's,
that's a uh,
pandered to by the universities,
which insist upon setting up a situation
where no one is ever offended by
anything,
any of the time.
And that's something I also can't
understand it all because.
Let me just say that's a huge point you
just made.
Okay.
Because it's the upper middle class of
the professional class who posts paul
and having the children.
Okay.
Because they go to law school,
they go to medical school in India and
they have the children after their
settled.
Okay.
In the.
In,
in a drop.
Okay.
So they're the ones.
What were injected this,
this,
this hypersensitive bourgeois id code
in,
into the universities.
Now my,
my parents were 20 when they married in
21 when they had me.
My father was um,
you know,
uh,
when I went to college on the gi bill
getting out of,
out of world war two.
So when I was born my father was still
in college and was sweeping floors and
so on.
I am the product of young parents and
nature once actually young parents.
Right.
Because because pregnancy is,
is,
is quicker,
it's safer.
Okay.
On.
And my parents had the energy.
okay.
To um,
you know,
this youthful energy that we can do
spirit that came out of world war two
and so on.
I'm part of that.
Then the,
then the only other sibling was born 14
years later.
My father,
this point was a college professor,
so she had completely different parents
than than I did,
so she,
she has very excellent manners and so I.
She's completely different.
okay.
All right.
And I'll have all this like moving the
energy of my parents were just a lot of
other teams,
but not today we have this situation.
No,
it's considered heresy to raise this
issue that you have have young women are
told,
okay,
there's one feature for you.
You are a future leader.
Okay.
You must,
you must move forward.
Okay.
Four years of college and it perhaps
into the professional class.
All right,
so it may be the women,
young women's bodies are signaling that
they want to be known.
Others maybe.
Maybe.
Maybe there are signals coming from the
body weight of maybe not wanting this,
this,
this system of education that was
devised for men.
Okay.
This being funneled the long channel
long.
It's nepotism.
Alright.
So young women feel they don't know why
they feel they had no sense of identity.
If they,
if they,
if they want to marry and drop out of
college and have have a baby,
they will be treated as traitors to
their class.
What you are future leaders have a baby
only working class women would do that.
I find working class women.
Okay.
In general.
Far more rounded as personalities.
The way they express themselves
forcefully.
They have body language that takes up
space.
A man says something to them on the
street.
They're right back in their face and so
on.
It this,
the bourgeois girls.
Okay.
Who are taught to.
They're there because they are a
special.
Okay.
We have to postpone actual life.
okay.
From for all these years,
they see these,
these other girls who are home who
misjudged the fraternity parties
setting.
These are the girls who like rotten for
parental protection and handholding on,
on the,
on the committee investigating what
would run on their date and so on and so
forth.
So.
So yes.
I think that yoU have located.
That's very interesting.
The idea that the,
these,
these young girls who are so sensitive.
Okay.
In college,
so I'm able to handle their sex life are
the product of older parents because
they went through the professional
career track.
Yes,
and they are.
They have not had the experience of the
competitiveness,
you know,
end up in and teasing of other siblings
and they don't know how to.
Well also the thing about young parents
is they don't care as much as older
parents and not actually turns out to be
better because what you really want for
your children is minimum necessary
intervention.
Right.
And the developmental literature is
actually quite clear on this.
So if you're at home with your child,
what the best rule that you can play is
to be there but not to be interacting
with the child all the time.
the child should be off doing whatever
it is the children do,
which generally is playing with other
children,
right.
Without it being mediated.
Also by screens and,
and technology because that's how they
formulate their identity and that's how
they learned to play games with other
people and the parent is supposed to be
there as a recourse for the child when
they go out a little bit farther than
they can tolerate in the half to come
back and get some security.
And so,
but that isn't,
that's especially not what happens.
Two single children because they're
basically raised as miniature adults.
So when I wonder too,
like how much of the antipathy towards
these are dark musings and I would say
how much of the antipathy towards man
that's being generated by say college
age women is a,
a deep repugnance for the role that
they've been designed.
And a disappointment with the man for
who,
you know,
like,
you think of those carpathian um,
or,
or uh,
uh,
I can't remember the culture.
The basic marit marital routine was to
ride into the village and grab the bride
and runaway with her on a horse.
Right.
It's like the like the motorcycle gang
member who rips the too naive woman out
of girl,
out of the of family.
There used to be bribed,
stealing.
It was quite,
quite,
quite widespread.
Right?
Well,
so I kind of wonder if part of the
reason that modern university age women
aren't so art so angry is because that
fundamental feminine role is actually
being denied to them and they're.
They're objecting to that at a really,
really fundamental level.
Like a level of,
of primitive outrage at
what's happened is the chaos that my
generation of the sixties be released
through the sexual revolution.
I went when I arrived in college in
1964,
w,
w the colleges were still acting in
local parentis in place of a parent.
So my dormitory,
all women's dormitory,
we women had to sign in at 11:00
at night.
The men could run free the entire night.
So it was my generation of women that
rose up and said,
give us the same freedom as men have and
the colleges replied,
no,
I'm in the world is dangerous.
you could be raped.
We have to protect you against.
Right?
And what we said,
okay,
was give us the freedom to risk rape.
Okay.
The,
so what that did,
today's women don't understand.
It's a freedom that you want.
It's the same freedom that gay men have
when they go and they pick up a stranger
or someplace they know it's dangerous.
They know they could end up beaten up or
killed.
Okay?
But they find it hot.
If you want freedom,
if you want equality,
okay,
then you have to stop behaving like a
man.
And so what we did is we gave freedom to
these young women for several
generations,
but my generation had been raised and a
far more resilient and robust culture.
Okay.
We had the strength,
okay.
To know what we wanted and to fight for
what we wanted.
These young women have been raised in
this protective terribly protected ways.
Right?
So I think in some strAnge thing,
you know,
the fashion that all of these demands
for intrusion from these stalinist
committees,
sexual,
you know,
investigating dates and so on.
It's a way to re institute,
okay,
the rules that my generation through out
the window.
And I.
So I think these young women are
desperate.
Not only that,
but I have spoken out very strongly in,
you know,
in a,
in a piece I wrote for time magazine
isn't my most recent book,
the idea that the raising the drinking
age in this country.
Okay.
From 18 to 21.
It's had a direct result.
Okay.
In these,
in these disasters of binge drinking
fraternity parties because to la,
let couch students the way we could go
out at as freshman have a beer sit any
protected adult environment,
learn how to have discourse with the
opposite sex in,
in a safe environment.
Right?
And so on.
And you and,
and the.
And not today.
Okay.
Because because of the stupid role that
the young people can't even buy a drink
in a bar until they're 21.
We have these fraternity parties that
are like the caveman era.
Well,
of course in,
in this modern age disadvantages men,
gay men want to hook up and men wanted
to have sex.
Women don't understand what men want.
Women,
women I put out because they're hoping
that maybe the men will continue to be
interested in them.
Okay.
The man just wants to experience.
That the hormones drive toward Jordan.
To me,
I,
I've,
I've theorized.
Okay.
That the,
you know,
the sex drive in men is intertwined
with,
with hunted pursuit.
Okay.
Yeah,
I feel absolutely.
This is what women don't understand.
Okay.
If it.
And if women understood what I
understand from my transgender
perspective,
right.
These women on the streets.
Okay.
I'm you.
I'm obviously,
you know,
but madonna and admirer and you know,
and I,
I support pornography and prostitution
so I don't want what I'm about to say.
The seem conservative and then it isn't.
Okay.
What I'm saying is the women on the
street,
young women who are,
who are jogging,
okay.
With no bra on.
Okay.
Short shorts and have and have any
earbuds in their ears.
Okay.
Just jogging the long line because I saw
these women do not understand the nature
of the human mind.
They do not understand the nature of
psychosis.
Okay.
And this intertwining them,
talking about the hunt,
the hunter pursued things.
They're triggering a hunter thing.
Just what?
What,
what?
What do what you have talked about in
terms of the zebra heard.
Okay.
They are triggering the hunt game.
A impulse in psychotic men.
Okay.
I have it here.
There goes.
I'm very appetizing and,
and totally oblivious animal.
Okay.
Bouncing along here.
Sorry.
And we're,
we're in a period now where psychosis is
not understood at all.
Okay.
Then a young women who has had no
exposure to movies like psycho.
Okay.
Was the,
the,
you know,
the kind of rapists serial murder thing.
So on the kind of strange dynamic that
has to do with it with an assault on the
mother and margo,
you know,
in,
in the,
in the mind of the psychotic.
But I think that is an incredible night.
He became these young women are emerging
and going to college and in this
incredible environment of sec orgiastic
sexual experience in fraternity houses.
They're completely unprepared for it.
And,
and so you're getting all this outrage
or feminist rhetoric has gotten more and
more extreme in its portrayal of men is
evil,
but in fact what we have is a cast is a,
is a chaos in the sexual realm because
the girls have not been told anything
real in terms of biological substrate.
There's full of lies about what
constitutes consent to.
Exactly.
And it's become something that's
essentially portrayed linguistically as
a sequence of progressive contracts,
which you know,
is.
It's.
Well,
I think,
you know,
I've thought for awhile that we're
living in the delusional fantasy of a
naive 13 year old girl that's basically
sums up our culture and I look at all
these sexual rules that permeate the,
the,
the academia and I think two things.
The first thing I think As well,
I know because I was an alcohol
researcher for a long time and you know
that fIfty percent of violent crimes are
directly attributable to alcohol.
So if you're a murdered,
there's about a 50 percent chance that
you're drunk and about a 50 percent
chance that the person who kills you is
drunk.
And the alcohol is the only drug that we
know that actually amplifies aggression.
It does that in laboratory situations.
Plus it's a great disinhibitor,
right?
so what alcohol does is it,
it doesn't make you to the future
consequences of your actions because if
you ask someone who's drunk about the
consequences of something stupid,
they can tell you what the consequences
are,
but it makes you not care.
And it does that because it's
technically an exile lytic,
like,
like barbiturates or benzodiazepines.
and it also has a,
as an activating a property for many
people who drink.
So it's,
it's a stimulant and a and an anxiolytic
at the same time in a very,
very potent,
very potent for both of them.
And you know,
we put young people together and douse
them in alcohol,
right at the binge drinking level.
and then,
which also interferes with memory
consolidation,
which of course makes things much more
complex.
And then we're surprised when there are
sexual misadventures and you know,
and then it's also attributed almost
purely to the predatory element that's,
that's,
uh,
part and parcel of masculinity.
But a true,
a tremenDous amount of that is also
naive and stupidity,
you know,
because we expect like eight to 18 year
old guys,
especially the ones that aren't,
that haven't been successful with girls,
which is like 85 percent of them because
the successful men are a very small
percentage of men.
The 85 percent who haven't been
successful with men or with women,
they don't know what the hell they're
doing it all right in part of the reason
they're getting drunk is to garner up
enough courage to actually make an
advance.
Because I think another thing that women
don't understand,
especially with regards to young men,
is just exactly how petrifying a
attractive woman who's of say,
somewhat higher status actually is to a
young guy in it.
There's lots of guys that wrIte me
constantly and people that I've worked
with that are so terrified of women,
they can't even talk to them.
it's very,
very common.
Well,
I take a very firm position,
which is that I want college
administration so state totally out of
the social lives of the students.
If a crime is committed,
it should be reported to the police.
I've been writing now for 20,
25 years now.
Right,
but,
but it's not the business of any college
administration to take any notice of
what the students say to each other,
say to each other as well as do with
each other.
Okay.
I want it to totally stop is fascism?
Yeah.
The worst.
I agree.
While you're sitting,
it's.
I think it's fascism of the worst kind
because it's an.
It's a new kind of fascism,
you know,
it's,
it's partly generated by legislation.
So the like the title nine men memo that
was written in 2011.
I recently got a copy of that god damn
thing.
That was one polluting bit of
legislation.
That was.
That memo basically told universities
that unless they set up a parallel court
system,
they were going to be denied central
funding.
It is absolutely unbelievable.
We had a ball and it will in the
leftists are supporting list.
I know,
I know.
That shows.
There is no authentic campus.
Leftism I'm sorry.
It's a fraud.
Okay.
Let me think.
The faculty should be fighting the
administration.
You're on this federal federal
regulation of how we're supposed to
behave on camp.
Well,
how can you be so how can you be so
naive and foolish to think that taking
an organization like the university,
which already has plenty to do and
forcing it to become a pseudo legal
system that parallels the legal system,
could possibly be anything but utterly
catastrophic.
It would mean you have to know
absolutely nothing about the legal
system and about the tremendous period
of evolution that produced what's
actually a stellar system and an
adversarial system that protects the
rights of the accused and of the end of
the victim and to replace that with an
ad hoc bureaucracy that has pretty much
essentially the same degree of power as
the court system with absolutely none of
the training and none of the guarantees
and to get real cards.
That piece that I wrote about date rape,
it was in january of 1991 a news day got
the most controversial thing I ever
wrote in my entire career.
I attack the entire thing and I demanded
the college has standing back and get
out of the social lives of the students,
so on and people.
The reaction people tried to recall,
they called the president of my
university,
tried to get me fired.
You can believe in hysteria.
Okay.
Right.
I can believe it.
Yeah.
It won't cost them anything and it.
If anything that says to women,
okay,
but they should be responsible for their
own choices is regarded as reactionary.
Are they kidding me?
Okay.
This is such a big trail of authentic
feminism in my view.
Well,
it's the ultimate betrayal of authentic
feminism because it's.
It,
it.
It's an invitation of all the things
that you might be paranoid about with
regards to the patriarchy back into your
life.
Right?
It's an insistence that the most
intrusive part of the tie,
ironical,
king come and take control over the most
intimate details of your life.
Incredible.
On the assumption is that that's going
to make your life better rather than
worse.
Right?
Yeah,
and not to mention this idea of,
you know,
this,
the stages of verbal consent as if,
as if your impulse is based in the body,
have anything to do with words.
So I mean that's the whole point is you
know,
you're allowed to abandon,
okay.
You know,
that part of the brain that's so,
and it traveled with words.
I mean
actually a marker of,
of lack of social ability to have to do
that because if you're a sophisticated,
it's not like if you're dancing with
someone,
it's not like you call out the moves,
right?
If you have to do that,
well then you're,
you're,
you're more worse than the neophyte,
right?
You're an awkward neophyte fight and
anybody with any sense should get the
hell away from you.
And so if you're reduced to the point
where you have to verbally negotiate
every element of intimate interaction,
then what a downer that eds.
But uh,
what I,
what an unbelievably,
what would you call it?
Naive and pathological view of the
manner in which human beings interact.
There's no sophistication in that.
Well,
what I'm worried about also in this age
of social media,
uh,
I've noticed as a,
as a teacher in the classroom,
that the young people are so used to
communicating now by cell phone.
Okay.
My iphone,
that's,
they're losing body language and facial
expressions.
Okay.
Which I think is going to compound the
problem with these dating,
uh,
encounters.
Okay.
Because the ability to read the human
face and into,
into,
into read little tiny inflections of
emotion was I think my generation got
that from looking at great foreign films
with,
with our,
with our long takes because you'd have
jon morrow and catherine deneuve in like
a potential romantic encounters and you
could use to the tiniest little little
inflections that,
that signal communication or sexual
readiness or,
or irony or skepticism or distance or
whatever.
But the inability to read the other
people's intentions.
Okay.
That I think this is going to be a
disaster.
I'm a guy,
I just,
I just noticed that,
um,
how year by year,
okay.
The students are becoming much more flat
affect and they in themselves complained
that they'll sit in the same room with
someone and be texting to each other.
Okay.
Yup.
Yeah.
Well there's a,
there's a piece of evidence to that
supports that to some degree.
So women with brothers are less likely
to get raped.
And the reason for that is that they've
learned that nonverbal language deeply.
Right.
And they can,
they can,
they can spot the.
Okay.
But I,
I have noticed,
okay.
Uh,
in my,
in my career.
Okay.
That the women who have many brothers.
Are very good.
Okay.
As administrators and as business
people,
because they don't take men seriously.
Okay.
They regard but they,
they,
they saw their brothers.
They were brothers are jokes.
Okay.
But they know how to control men.
While it,
while they still like men.
Okay.
They admired man.
Alright.
So this is something that I have seen
repeatedly
that would be also reflective of the
problem of fewer and fewer siblings.
Yes,
that's right.
Okay.
Yeah.
And I've noticed this in publishing.
Okay.
That's that the,
um,
the,
the women who have this job,
the job of publicist.
Okay.
And rise to the top is as manager of
publicity.
Okay.
Their ability to take charge of men and,
and,
and they're humorous men that like the
end of in and they have great
relationships with men because they
don't have the sense of resentment and
in,
in worry and anxiety and they don't see
men as aggressors.
Okay.
Right.
And I think it's another thing too,
is that as feminism,
um,
you know,
uh,
moved into its presence in assistant
videology.
Okay.
It has tended to denigrate motherhood
as,
as a lesser order of human experience.
And,
and to enshrine,
of course abortion.
I am 100 percent of abortion rights.
I belonged to planned parenthood for
years until I finally rejected it as a
branch of the democratic party,
my party and so on.
Um,
but,
but as motherhood became excluded,
as,
as feminism became obsessed.
Okay.
With the,
with the,
with a professional woman.
Okay.
I feel that the lessons are that mothers
learn had been lost.
Okay.
Yeah.
To to,
to,
to feminism,
which is okay if,
if,
if the,
the mothers who who bear boy children.
Okay.
Understand the fragility of men,
the fragility and boys.
They understand it.
They don't,
they don't seem to boys.
And then as a menace they understand
that the greatest strength of women.
Okay.
So there's this tenderness and
connectedness between the,
between the mother and the and the boy
child.
Okay.
W when motherhood is part of the
experience of,
of women who are discussing gender.
So what we have today is this,
this does gender.
The lg has risen up on campuses where
we're all.
None of the.
None of the girls know the students have
married.
None of them had children.
Okay.
And you have,
you have women.
Some of them have had children,
but a lot of them are lesbians or like
or like arguing or like professional
women and so on.
Okay.
So there's this whole tenderness and
forgiven.
Forgiveness.
Okay.
And encouragement that women do to two
boys.
Okay.
The fragility,
they don't understand this
hypersensitivity of boys.
It's not understood.
Okay.
Instead button.
Boys are seen as somehow a more
privileged.
Okay.
And somehow,
you know,
their,
their energy level is interpreted as
aggression.
Okay.
Potential violence and so on.
Alright.
Uh,
so I,
I think that that is what we would do
better.
Okay.
If we would have.
I have proposed.
Okay.
That colleges should allow.
The moment a woman is entered,
it's entered.
Okay.
She has entrusted at college for life.
And that she,
that she should be free to leave.
Okay.
To have babies when she,
when her body wants that babies,
when it's healthy to have them and then
return have heaven had the occasional
course again build up credits and
fathers.
I mean you might be able to do it as as
well and so on,
to get married.
Women,
women with children into the classroom.
The moment that happens and it's
happened after world war ii.
Okay.
We've hit a lot of married guys in the
classroom.
Okay.
And so on.
Not yet.
Not that many women experience of a
married person with a family talking
about gender,
but most of them gender stuff will be
laughed out of the room.
Okay.
If you had a real mother in there who
would experienced childbirth and had had
rate and it was raising boys and
consumer,
why do I think that that's also
something that has led to this,
this,
this incredible art artificiality and
uh,
and hysteria.
Okay.
Feminist rhetoric.
There's,
there's another strange element to that
which is that on the one hand,
the radical feminist types,
the neo marxist postmodernists are,
are very much opposed to the patriarchy,
let's say.
And that's,
that unidimensional ideological
represented
mean perhaps the word can be applied to
republican rome and that's it.
Okay.
Well,
and then maybe it can be applied
usefully to certain kinds of tyranny,
but not to a society that's actually
functional.
Victorian england one,
arguably.
Okay.
But other than that,
and to use the word patriarchy and that
ended at a slapdash way.
So feel emma tourists are absolutely,
absolutely.
You know,
just shows people know nothing about
history.
Whatever have you ever had,
had done no reading.
So.
And so what confuses me about is that
despite the fact that the patriarch is
viewed as this essentially evil entity
and that that's associated with the
masculine energy that built this
oppressive structure,
the antithesis of that,
which would actually be femininity as
far as I can tell,
which is tightly associated with care
and with child rearing is also
denigrated.
So it's like the only proper role for
women to adopt is a patriarchal role
despite the fact that the patriarchy is
something that's entirely corrupt.
So the hypothesis seems to be that the
patriarchy would be just fine if women
ran it.
So no changes.
It's just that would just be a
transformation of leadership and somehow
that would,
that would rectify the fundamental
problem even though it's hypothetically
supposed to be structural.
Okay.
So I'm going to close with something.
So,
you know,
there are elements in my character that
are optimistic.
You know,
I've,
I've looked,
for example,
I worked for the un committee and on the
relationship between economic
development,
sustainability,
and I found out a variety of things that
were very optimistic.
Like the fact that,
you know,
tom set out to have poverty between 2000
and 2015 worldwide and actually hit that
by about 2010.
Right?
So we're in the period of the fastest
transformation of the bottom strata of
the world's population into something
approximating middleclass that's ever
occurred.
And there's all these great
technological innovations on the horizon
and it looks to me like things could go
extraordinarily well if we were careful,
but I'm not optimistic and maybe that's
me.
I'm pessimistic because I also see that
there's five or six things happening,
all of which appear at the level of
catastrophe that are all happening at
the same time.
And so one of the things that I'd like
to ask you is like what do you see
happening in the next 10 years in the,
in the universities are in culture at
large and I mean you just put forward a
proposal for the universities for the
treatment of women,
which I think is very interesting.
One because women do have a different
timeframe than men,
but like what the hell is the proper way
forward?
I've been encouraging young men to tell
the truth and to take responsibility and
there's a huge market for that message,
but,
but I'm not convinced by any stretch of
the imagination that it's enough.
What like when you look forward and you
try to be optimistic,
what the hell do you see?
Well,
and in the largest scale,
um,
I'm concerned about the future western
culture because as a student of history,
it looks too much to me like ancient
rome.
Okay.
Which became overexpanded,
uh,
which became a,
it was at the mercy of a bureaucratic,
um,
uh,
the creep.
Okay.
And can you imagine one of yesterday,
right?
And in and roman identity eventually got
blurred.
Okay.
In,
in the incorporation of so many
different cultures,
which at first seemed like a healthy
kind of multiculturalism,
but eventually overexpand and simply
collapse of its own way.
But I,
I,
and I,
so I am concerned what the weather
western culture is in a rapid decline.
I think it would be very easy because we
are so interconnected and so overcomplex
very easy,
you know,
to bring it to ruin.
It would only take one major natural
disaster,
you know,
to do that,
but the university themselves,
I mean,
I think people are all of a sudden in
the United States,
much more attentive to issues of
political correctness because of the
riots at berkeley,
which was the,
you know,
which was the capital of free speech.
I mean,
the free speech movement happened in the
spring before I entered college in 1964
to one of the great principles and
inspirational stories of my entire life.
Mario savio was an assertion of,
of the,
of the supremacy of free thought and
free speech.
These.
Okay.
I,
uh,
so I think that perhaps,
you know,
we might just have turned a corner,
but it's going to take a very,
very long time for the university to be
reformed.
I feel that the cafeteria menu,
okay,
of,
of the university curriculum has to be
abandoned.
That we must return to historical,
uh,
courses that begin in the earliest
period and this donation,
antiquity,
in order to give perspective,
you know,
to,
to our,
to our present an analysis of our
president at culture.
I want a 50 slash 50 to 75 percent of
college administrators fired.
Okay.
And the money be transferred over to,
um,
to,
to faculty into libraries,
into,
into instruction.
Okay.
Um,
I,
I think that,
um,
you know,
obviously the way things are being,
people are being trained right now,
including at the public school level.
Okay.
Is I think that I think the public
school level has gone to hell.
And when,
when,
when my mother came,
you know,
came to United States at age of six.
They were,
the old public school system was very
strict and therefore she has an
excellent education,
you know,
and um,
did got all a's in her,
in her even though she started out in
not speaking english,
spoke without an accent,
etc.
Okay.
So today this,
this kind of feel good.
The public school education,
which is,
which is a form of ideology in our
nation right now.
so it's all about the no bullying.
Okay.
And so,
and not about anything seriously about
no bullying.
Yes.
Yeah.
So I mean,
I can tell them in my own students,
I mean I've been teaching for 46 years
so I can tell them this slow degradation
of public school education.
Like I said,
they have to the point now that the
students have absolutely no sense of
world geography of world history and
they know absolutely nothing.
They don't know anything about wars and
the reality,
the barbaric reality of most of human
history.
Okay.
And what are triggers?
What a fantastic culture we live in.
And so now identity,
identity politics itself has just got to
stop.
I mean it was important.
Once again,
I was a rebel against the wasps.
Had gemini.
Okay.
New white anglo saxon,
protestant gemini.
In american culture it was,
it was suffocating.
I,
I was raised in the 19 fifties when
wasps controlled corporations and,
and,
and education and politics and so on.
And so identity politics was necessary
once.
Okay.
How do we asserted gay rights?
And was it was stonewall rebellion of
1969.
We assert,
we asserted okay.
The women's rights with a,
with the rebirth of second wave feminism
in the late 19 sixties.
Okay,
but this endless,
okay,
preoccupation with with a a fragmented
Identity,
we must return to the authentic that
needs six.
His vision,
which is about identity coming from
consciousness which transcends gender,
which transcends all these divisions of
race and ethnicity.
Okay.
Consciousness itself.
Right now there's no sense of that any
longer and that's what the 19 sixties.
That is a complete abandonment of
personal responsibility because that
consciousness,
I think symbolically and I got a lot of
this from yoga and also for american
government.
I mean that's the great logos of the
west,
right?
That's the transcendent principle,
which is his respect for the primacy of
individual consciousness and what goes
along with that primarily isn't
individual rights.
Although that's built into it.
I mean that's the reason we have
individual rights is for respect for
that,
but the responsibility that comes along
with being an individual instead of the
member of some group,
especially in victimized group,
which is like the assure.
I wrote an article with one of my
students who had toured the mass grave
sites and in the former yugoslavia,
you know,
and have been exposed to that sort of
thing and one of the things that our
research indicated was that the best
predictor of genocide is a victimization
on the part of the group that produces
the genocide.
Right.
A sense of an accelerated sense of
victimization and then it's,
well,
we get them before they get us.
So when everyone's being taught now that
they're a victim and then no one seems
to have any sense that,
you know,
that's part of the essential tragedy of
being that life is suffering and that
and that and that and that and that the
world rests on a foundation of
suffering.
It's nothing to take personally and it's
something to take responsibility for it
instead of blaming and,
and resentment and all of the things
that have polluted our universities and
our culture.
Well.
And then they'll also the abandonment of
the,
um,
of,
of the cannon.
Okay.
The people you know,
asserted that the canon was the product
of bias.
And again,
the va,
you know,
have a,
have a provincial elitists and so on,
but in point of fact,
as a student of history of the arts,
okay,
I can,
I can assure people that the canon.
Okay.
Oh the overwhelmingly so is,
is the result of what artists have
determined.
Okay,
we,
we say a work is important.
It's canonical because artists following
it.
Okay.
We're influenced by it and we have this
beautiful cascading tradition of
influence.
All right?
So that's another part of the
philistinism okay.
Of current education to,
to,
to believe that there are these external
reasons.
Okay.
For,
for the why a work last,
why a work written 500 years ago or a
thousand years ago has global relevance
as if it's some sort of political that's
based on power as if anybody could even
manage that no matter how nefarious
world.
But also,
you know,
we read in the sixties you had the,
had the idea,
okay,
there wasn't like a human human
sensibility that transcendent individual
nations and solid and that and that
there was this like rubric for cosmic
consciousness.
Okay.
This,
this sense of the universe as a whole
and just to see the human being in
relationship to great eternal principles
of life and death,
mortality and so on.
Whereas marxism is blind.
Marxism is very narrow.
All it sees as a society.
Okay?
It says nothing beyond society.
It doesn't seem nature.
Okay?
Mean it's absolutely mad.
Are you going to have a system being
taught,
okay,
in universities,
right?
Which,
which,
which thinks that this tiny thing of
society.
Okay.
Compared to the enormity and beauty of
nature.
Okay.
It shouldn't take all of our,
all of our,
you know,
absorb all of our energy and attention.
So,
I mean,
I just think that there's like a
parochialism and provincialism,
uh,
you know,
and it,
it,
and now all kinds of,
um,
you know,
systematized elitism in our current
education.
I just got to be rooted out and I want
to return to basics.
Great.
Simplicity's and I have all these
faculty members teaching their little
tiny courses that have to,
has to do with their own specialty.
That's got to stop.
And people,
people can pursue whatever they want in
their private research scholars.
Okay.
Certainly that's necessary,
but they must teach in the core
curriculum.
Uh,
and,
and people must decide what is crucial
for an educated person to know.
I do want a multicultural.
I do want a global curriculum like I
want.
I want all the cultures taught.
Okay?
Right.
This is not the answer.
Martin marxism,
this neo marxism in the university's
okay.
Is simply,
it's lazy.
It's a lazy way to assert
multiculturalism without actually doing
the research and the study of other
cultures.
Okay.
Alright,
good.
One to close on.
We agreed on everything I knew.
All right.
Great.